consacre la perte d'influencé américaine
dans cette partie
il est clair qu'avec cet accord le pôle
économique mondiale tant au niveau du
développement peu de leur activité est
dorénavant durablement installé sur le
continent asiatique avec son est
puissant tranché
rendez vous compte un espace économique
occupé par 2 milliards 200 millions
d'habitants qui représente 30% de la
production mondiale de richesse
il est triste et même inquiétant de
constater que l'europe se retrouve
aujourd'hui marginalisée par rapport à
la rcp
nora lakehal a été la première femme à
intégrer le groupe
islamisme radical de la saur c'est
l'élite des renseignements généraux de
la police française et c'était après les
attentats du 11 septembre
et quand on vient vous voir et qu'on
vous dit écoutez vous avez de la
première femme qui allait rentrer dans
ce service
vous ne pouvez absolument pas refusé
votre mission première est celle de
traquer ces terroristes ce prêcheur
salafistes il vous a des tranchées pour
reprendre un code policiers il vous a
reconnu qui va là c'est fini pour moi
est ce que je sors mon arme
tout est passé dans ma tête est ce que
vous avez appris de ces profils
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont chercher
d'ailleurs dans la religion le profil
vient toujours de la misère sociale
quand on écoute comme ça du mahler mais
quel est le rapport avec la radiation
mais c'est la radicalisation
il faut que nous reprenions la place
dans le cerveau des enfants et de la
jeunesse
[Musique]
l une vers une accélération de la
campagne de vaccination en france un
processus jugé trop long jusqu'ici mais
dès lundi les soignants de plus de 50
ans pourront se faire vacciner avec deux
mois d'avancé sur le calendrier initial
ce changement de cap olivier derand le
ministre de la santé emmanuel macron
et jeudi dernier donald trump il a
démarré la nouvelle année sur une
défaite cuisante le sénat américain
pourtant à majorité républicaine a
balayé son veto ou budget de la défense
la loi est définitivement adopté le
président sortant invite maintenant ses
partisans à manifester le 6 janvier
on la doit valider l'élection de john
dryden à la présidentielle les tensions
entre les etats-unis et l'iran elles se
sont renforcées la proche de
l'anniversaire de l'assassinât du
général iranien qassem suleimani l'un
des leaders des gardiens de la
révolution tué par une frappe américaine
à bagdad le 3 janvier 2020 aujourd'hui
leur chef promettent une riposte à tout
acte des états unis par ailleurs à terre
en dit vouloir enrichir son uranium à au
moins 20% au-delà du seuil fixé par les
accords de vienne est les détails c'est
à suivre dans cette édition
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france changement de
cap ou pas dans sa stratégie vaccinale
sous le feu des critiques en raison
d'une certaine lenteur à le gouvernement
étant la vaccination soignants de plus
de 50 ans dès lundi soit deux mois plus
tôt que prévu d'ailleurs des centres de
vaccination ouvriront dans les villes
avant le début du mois de février on
voit cela avec natacha perat tai chi va
piano va sano un proverbe italien que
l'on pourrait traduire en français par
qui va doucement va sûrement expression
qui colle parfaitement à la stratégie de
vaccination française
je ne confonds pas vitesse et
précipitation nous avons fait en france
un autre choix que je revendique qui est
de nous appuyer sur les médecins les
professionnels de santé de vacciner les
personnes âgées en ehpad et ne pas les
faire se déplacer
cela prend plus de temps au démarrage ce
délai jël assume
il est même revendiquer un démarrage
poussif assumée et revendiquée donc avec
à peine plus de 330 vaccination en
france depuis le début de la campagne
contre 2,7 millions aux etats-unis 1
million en israël six cent mille le
royaume uni ou encore 130 mille chez nos
voisins allemands
la france loin derrière tous les autres
donc mais d'après de monsieur vaccin du
gouvernement tout s'explique
cette stratégie est une conséquence elle
force à aller plus lentement car il faut
savoir qu'il ya environ 14000 ehpad en
france et que le vaccin est difficile à
transporter difficile à conserver pour
certains toutefois ces questions de
logistique cache en réalité tout autre
chose c'est une stratégie de lenteur
subi parce que nous ne sommes pas prêts
ça n'est pas en avant sont un tout petit
pas on arrivera à convaincre les
français au contraire on va les
convaincre qu'en les fêtes si on va si
lentement c'est qu'on n'est pas sûr de
soi et qu'il y à un danger pas sûr de
pas prêt depuis plusieurs jours les
critiques fusent et face à la polémique
sur la lenteur de la campagne de
vaccination le gouvernement a finalement
décidé de mettre un coup d'accélérateur
dans quelques semaines la vaccination
aura été proposée à l'ensemble des
personnes âgées
et nous serons au même niveau que les
pays qui ont procédé différemment sans
perte de chance au contraire nous avons
décidé en parallèle d'accélérer la
protection des publics prioritaires dès
lundi les soignants de 50 ans et plus
qui le souhaitent pourront se faire
vacciner dans les centres disposant déjà
de vaccins de plus avant le début
février deux premiers centres de
vaccination ouvriront en ville pour
commencer à vacciner les personnes âgées
de 75 ans et plus puis les 65 ans et
plus et cetera une heure après ses
tweets du ministre de la santé
emmanuel macron à lui même lors de ses
voeux pour 2021 appelé chez à mettre un
terme à je cite à cette lenteur
injustifiée l'espoir est là dans ce
vaccin que le génie humain a fêté à
devenir en un an seulement
c'était impensable il ya encore quelques
mois et je vous le dis avec beaucoup de
détermination ce soir je ne laisserai
personne jouer avec la sûreté et les
bonnes conditions encadrés par nos
scientifiques et nos médecins dans
lesquelles la vaccination doit se faire
et je ne les ferai pas davantage pour de
mauvaises raisons
une lenteur injustifiée s'installer
chaque français qui le souhaite doit
pouvoir se faire vacciner de manière
sûre et dans le bon ordre en commençant
par ceux qui présentent le plus de
risques
après une première livraison de 60 mille
doses de vaccin cinq cent mille doses
supplémentaires doivent arriver la
semaine prochaine et cent mille autres
chaque semaine jusqu'à la fin du mois de
février et elle vient peut être de là
l'accélération à présent revendiqué par
le gouvernement s'il ya en effet si peu
de vacciner en france c'est aussi parce
que le nombre de doses est aujourd'hui
limité ce choix de lenteur que disait
assumer le gouvernement serait en fait
un moyen de masquer une nouvelle car ans
après le scandale des masques et celui
des tests place un nouvelle polémique
cette fois sur les vaccins et on va
écouter ce propos stéphane rozès
politologue et président de la société
de conseil cap selon lui
à cette campagne de vaccination elle
manque de clarté et de transparence
au fond il n'y a eu aucune communication
gouvernementale ou présidentielle clair
sur cette campagne de vaccination il ya
eu des bribes d'arguments en fait il
n'ya pas une visibilité très nette sur
les effets des vaccins notamment celles
pour lesquelles il ya de nouvelles
technologies génétiques de vaccins je
sais par exemple find their et son
partenaire allemand et astrazeneca est
au fond on a entendu dire que la france
aurait pu laisser ses voisins et
partenaires tester en premier pour voir
si d'aventuré on terrain réel
il y aurait des effets secondaires
induits y est née face et le coronavirus
à impacter considérablement les
économies du monde entier en argentine
pour y faire face et aider les plus
démunis le sénat a voté une loi
instaurant un impôt sur les grandes
fortunes
l'initiative qui séduit déjà au du
royaume uni au fmi qui suggère même que
tous les états suivent le modèle
argentin les précisions avec d'assez mme
shelly taxer les plus riches pour
alléger la dette et faire face aux
chorales à virus
si la france se montre réticente sur ce
sujet sensible d'autres pays étudient
déjà l'option une option qui
contrairement à ce que l'on pourrait
croire à vient des riches eux mêmes une
poussée d'altruisme dans un monde malade
comme une façon de se rendre utile et
d'apporter sa pierre à l'édifice dans
une lettre ouverte baptisé millionnaire
for humanity plus d'une centaine de
millionnaires on demandait à être taxés
immédiatement et de manière permanente
nous ne sommes pas ceux qui soignent les
malades dans les unités de soins
intensifs
nous ne conduisons pas les ambulances
qui amène les malades à l'hôpital
nous ne sommes pas ceux qui regardent
nice les rayons des épiceries ou qui
délivre de la nourriture de porte à
porte les problèmes causés et révélé par
le kobe 19 ne peuvent être résolus par
la charité
les chefs de gouvernement doivent
prendre la responsabilité de lever les
fonds via une augmentation permanente
des taxes sur les plus fortunés de la
planète des gens comme nous depuis des
années des milliers à des telles que
warren buffet ou encore bill gates
demande à être taxés davantage un appel
qui semble avoir été entendu et
notamment pas là webtaxes commisssion au
royaume uni ceux ci ont rendu un rapport
au début du mois de décembre qui
démontre qu'en taxant les plus riches
pendant cinq ans le gouvernement
pourrait récolter 260 milliards de
livres soit plus de 280 milliards
d'euros une option sérieusement
envisagée par le royaume uni pour faire
écho à l'argentine qui n'a pas hésité à
mettre en place une taxe exceptionnelle
pour faire face à la crise c'est ainsi
qu'au pays de maradona et de messi 12000
argentin parmi les plus aisés du pays
ont été mis à contribution pour
permettre à l'état de financer les aides
sociales
les subventions aux pme mais également
les programmes d'exploitation gazière
dans ce pays miné par une crise sans
précédent à l'état espère récolter plus
de 3 milliards d'euros pour limiter les
effets de la pandémie
alors que certains représentants du
monde des affaires dénonce une politique
confiscatoire et une pression fiscale
d'autres applaudissent cette décision en
précisant que l'impact réel sur les
grandes fortunes sera très peu
conséquent ces personnes disposent en
moyenne de liquidités 25 fois plus élevé
que le montant qui va leur être prélevés
c'est une taxe qui cherche à encourager
le rapatriement d'actifs détenus à
l'étranger et à stimuler les
investissements en argentine et si le
cas argentin allait servir d'exemple au
reste de la planète
c'est en tout cas une initiative saluée
par le fonds monétaire international
celui là même qui avait mis à genoux
l'argentine dans les années 2000
l'institution internationale a récemment
appelé les gouvernements à envisager de
taxer davantage les ménages les plus
riches et les entreprises les plus
lucratives
les gouvernements devraient envisager
des impôts plus élevés pour les ménages
les plus aisés et les entreprises très
rentable ces revenus supplémentaires
contribuerait à payer des services
essentiels comme la santé et les filets
de sécurité sociale pendant une crise
qui touche de manière disproportionnée
les plus pauvres de la société alors que
dans l'hexagone est la pandémie de
qu'ovide a fait exploser la pauvreté
et que le plan de relance du
gouvernement ne semble pas connaître de
limites
la nécessité s'impose de trouver au plus
vite de l'argent alors comment et sous
quelle forme
une taxe spéciale sur les fortunes au
profit des plus pauvres
l'acteur français vincent lindon l'a
déjà proposé une taxe baptisée jean
valjean qui proposait déjà de taxer les
riches pour soulager les pauvres
belle initiative mais très vite oublié
organiser un come back de l' isf la bête
noire des fortunes de france et
envisager à pau bercy et pourtant l'étau
semble se resserrer sur le gouvernement
alors qu'une troisième vague pourrait se
dessiner avec une dette qui explose
atteignant 116 4 % du pib fin septembre
soit 2600 74 milliards d'euros la france
n'a jamais été aussi endetté depuis la
seconde guerre mondiale une crise
historique qui pourrait pousser le
gouvernement à revoir sa feuille de
route est peut-être envisager de faire
comme l'argentine taxer les riches pour
payer la crise et pour en parler un os
rejoignons philippe béchade et les
rédacteurs en chef de la bourse au
quotidien bonsoir à vos philippe béchade
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur
arte france
taxer les plus riches pour éponger la
dette de coronavirus selon vous est ce
que c'est une bonne méthode
en tout cas c'est une méthode bien
française
taxer les riches c'est là parce qu'un
réflexe c'est la réponse qui semble
aller de soi ça ça l'apparence du bon
sens mais ce que nous vivons aujourd'hui
beaucoup plus complexe et va bien au
delà du creusement des inégalités un
creusement là qui n'est plus seulement
abyssal qui devient carrément obscène
dans une économie en croissance
on va dire que si les riches
s'enrichissent tandis que des classes
défavorisées moyennes ou moyennes sup se
voyait chacun le créditer une part de la
richesse créée on pourrait se dire bon
c'est un peu inégal il y en a qui
prennent plus que d'autres sauf que là
cette année c'est beaucoup plus
troublant est quasiment surréaliste
il n'y a pas de richesses créées dans
une économie en récession et pourtant
l'enrichissement des plus riches alors
là
attention pour moi à l'enregistrement
les plus riches ça concerne environ 0 1%
de la population
les banques centrales ont injecté cette
année environ dix mille milliards dans
l'économie mondiale et les 0 1% ont vu
leur richesse augmenter de 7500
milliards et ses 7500 milliards ce n'est
pas la richesse puisque nous sommes en
récession je le rappelle donc c'est de
l'argent magiques créés par les banques
centrales
mais qui atterrissent par des mécanismes
un peu complexe je n'ai pas les détails
mais en tout cas on le voit bien les 9
milliards des banques centrales se sont
retrouvé pratiquement à 80% sur les
comptes en banque des 0 0 1% les plus
riches et donc là il ya quelque chose
qui va bien au delà
mais de l'idée simplement de taxer les
riches il ya quelque chose qui ne va
plus du tout dans le système il ya une
véritable désintégration du contrat
social en tout cas à l'initiative des
taxes est allé pleurnicher et salué par
plusieurs pays mais aussi par le fmi
quand en fait vous alors le fmi et même
plutôt ou madame lagarde était à sa tête
avant de prendre la présidence de la bce
elle avait également fait écho justement
à ces appels de warren buffett et
d'autres milliardaires qui trouvait
totalement est totalement inconcevable
de payer moins d'impôts que leur
jardinier leur femme de ménage ou ou
leur chauffeur
le problème c'est que l'amérique de
trappes
elle a encore réduit l'imposition sur
les plus riches
et quelle est la richesse en fait qu'on
voudrait taxer ces de la richesse
financière
si on taxe de la richesse immobilière ou
patrimoine patrimoniale elle revient
effectivement à ce fameux jsf qui
frappait des gens qui se retrouvent et
riche parce qu'ils avaient une maison à
l'île de ré
ray ou un chalet sur les hauteurs de val
d'isère et que d'un seul coup ce bien
vallée de trois millions ils se
retrouvaient taxable sans en tirer
vraiment de revenus ou ou de richesse
voilà le problème c'est que là on est le
face à un accroissement spectaculaire
historique de la richesse financière et
c'est à ce problème qu'il faut
s'attaquer
et là la source elle se situe du côté
des mécanismes de transmission de
l'argent créé par les dans le central
vers l'économie réelle
or cet argent créé ne va pas vers
l'économie réelle il va donc gonfler la
valeur des actifs financiers
alors ça serait pas un problème
véritablement 6,7
ces plus values étaient réinvestis dans
l'économie réelle si les ultra-riches
créer des emplois consommer énormément
biens et services on va dire que ça
remettrait de l'huile dans les rouages
économiques
si côté de la france les pêcheurs du
côté de la france on semble aussi être
frileux 1 à taxer les grosses fortunes
et par ailleurs il ya un plan de relance
à hauteur de 100 milliards d'euros
envisagés pour justement éviter
d'augmenter les impôts la position de la
france
comment vous l'analysez le problème
c'est que la france souffre déjà d'une
sur fiscalité et si les riches ont mis
leur argent dans des paradis fiscaux
c'est que la france est déjà perçu comme
un enfer fiscal
donc on sait très bien que la taxation
des rites de la taxation des riches ne
rapportera quasiment rien puisque les
fortunes sont déjà hors d'atteinte du
fisc français
la seule chose que va pouvoir taxer le
fisc français ce sont les petits riches
ceux qui gagnent parce que la richesse
bien sûr est ce que ce sont ceux qui
gagnent plus de 3000 5 plus de 4000
56000 où se situe la richesse mais là on
change complètement d'échelle
quand on parle d'eux
dont la fortune se chiffrent en
centaines de millions en milliards et là
c'est de l'argent qui est totalement
inaccessible au fisc donc si on pense à
nouveau à taxer les riches
on va taxer ce que le fisc peut peut
contraindre mais ceux qui ont vraiment
cet ultra richesses sont complètement à
l'abri que ce soit le fisc français le
fisc luxembourgeois le fisc américain
donc quand on parle de taxer les riches
une nouvelle fois ça va tomber sur les
mêmes toujours ceux qui sont entre 4000
et 10000 euros de revenus par mois mais
il est très très riches vont de nouveau
y échapper c'est ça c'est ça le problème
c'est que cette cette grande grandes
fortunes financières elle est
aujourd'hui inaccessible c'est merci
beaucoup philippe béchade d'avoir
répondu en direct à ado question je
rappelle que vous êtes rédacteur en chef
de la bourse
au quotidien on en vient maintenant à
cette manifestation pour demander la
réquisition des logements vides
a paris une centaine à deux personnes
rassemblées à proximité du ministère du
logement vous voyez le cortège qui a
pris ensuite la direction de la gare
saint lazare dans le pays trois cent
mille personnes sont sans domicile fixe
et 2 8 millions sont considérés comme
mal logé à l'origine de cette
mobilisation le collectif droit au
logement demande l'application de la loi
sur la réquisition à des logements vides
disponible et il y en aurait des
millions écouter son porte-parole on est
là avec les collectifs de sans abri le
dal et plein d'autres associations et
collectifs pour demander au ministère du
logement qui est juste là demandé à
manama rebond de réquisitionner le froid
arrive
on est on a eu nos risques
d'augmentation importante de la pandémie
et on a trois millions de logements
vacants
donc qu'est ce qu'on fait dans ce pays
alors qu'il ya des gens qui sont dehors
qui sont dans la rue qui crève à petit
feu on a des logements qui reste vacant
par négligence ou par spéculation
c'est une honte c'est comme si on
laissait comme sur détruisaient des de
la nourriture devant des affamés c'est
la même chose et donc là maintenant il
faut réquisitionner
on demande à ce gouvernement d'appliquer
la loi tout simplement la loi la loi de
réquisition de gaulle l'a fait chirac a
fait y en a plein qui l'ont fait avant
eux pourquoi ils ont pu ne faut pas eu
le groupe de soutien d'al qaïda au sahel
le gsm a revendiqué l'attaqué qui a
coûté la vie à trois soldats français au
mali le 28 décembre dernier l'a fait via
sa plateforme à de propagande
j'ai essayé ma évoque notamment les
caricatures de mahomet la présence
militaire française dans la sous région
ainsi que la politique du gouvernement
français vis-à-vis des musulmans de
france
la branche d'al qaida n'a pour le moment
pas donné de détails sur la tac
les etats unis sont le pays le plus
touché par le col et 19 dans nombre de
morts que l'occar et le vaccin donne de
l'espoir mais les embellies se font très
rares le rythme à des nouvelles
infections s'accélère on parle même d'un
robot épidémique spectaculaire les
précisions avec françois des sketches
à la veille du nouvel an des personnes
se pressent pour avoir le résultat après
cette fête testé sur le nouveau site de
dépistage rapide de l'aéroport
international de los angeles
des millions d'américains se sont
déplacés pour les fêtes de fin d'année
malgré les nombreux appels des autorités
à rester chez soi sur le week-end du 26
décembre l'agent chargé des contrôles de
sécurité dans les aéroports a même
recensé un record du nombre de passagers
depuis la mi mars le nombre de personnes
positives au kovy 19 a de son côté
explosé avec un million de cas recensés
en moins d'une semaine à travers le pays
ces derniers jours
le variant britannique du virus a été
identifié dans plusieurs états de
l'ouest américain
mais le célèbre immunologue anthony
fauci assure ne pas être surpris ni
particulièrement inquiet et bien tout
d'abord je ne suis pas surpris qu'il y
ait un cas et probablement même plus en
californie et nous allons probablement
en abordant notre état je pense que cela
va arriver parce que si vous avez
beaucoup de cas au royaume uni avec tous
les voyages non seulement directement
vers les états unis mais aussi à travers
d'autres pays par intermittence comme à
l'est du royaume uni à la france puis de
la france aux états unis et c'est donc
je ne pense pas que les californiens
devrait sentir que c'est quelque chose
d'étrange c'est quelque chose qui est
attendu les américains s'accroche malgré
tout à l'espoir d'une immunisation
rapide de la population avec le
lancement le 14 décembre dernier de la
plus grande campagne de vaccination de
l'histoire des états unis depuis
selon les chiffres du centre de contrôle
et de prévention des maladies
environ 3 millions de personnes ont déjà
reçu la première dose de leurs vaccins
très loin de l'objectif des 20 millions
de personnes vaccinées avant 2021 promis
par l'administration trump un retard
critiquée par le président élu joe biden
m'est imputé à la lenteur de certains
états par donald trump
certains et attardo goku à vacciner
malgré une distribution de vaccins
réussi et à très grande échelle par le
gouvernement fédéral ils le feront
l'effort de distribution et
d'administration du vaccin ne progresse
pas comme il le devrait
il y a quelques semaines
l'administration trump a suggéré que 20
millions d'américains pourraient être
vaccinées d'ici la fin décembre
ici le programme de vaccination continue
d'avancer à ce rythme là il faudra des
années et non des mois pour vacciner
tous les américains joe biden a par
ailleurs demandé à donald trump de se
faire inoculer le vaccin pour montrer
l'exemple
selon un récent sondage 64% des
américains envisagent de se faire
vacciner
[Musique]
et puis ce désaveu pour donald trump le
sénat à majorité républicaine a
contourné son veto au budget de la
défense comme avant lui la chambre des
représentants dirigé par les démocrates
la loi est donc définitivement adopté
donald trump qui conteste toujours la
victoire de joe biden à la
présidentielle il appelle maintenant ses
partisans à manifester le 6 janvier jour
le congrès doit invalider définitivement
l'issue du scrutin présidentiel on le
rappelle à donald trump quittera à la
maison blanche le 20 janvier siens
le grand rassemblement de protestation à
washington dc aura lieu à 11 heures le 6
janvier détails sur le lieu à venir
stopper le vol
les tensions se sont accentuées entre
l'iran les états unis à la proche de
l'anniversaire de l'assassinât du
général qasem soleimani tué par une
frappe américaine le 3 janvier 2020 il
s'agit du chef des opérations des
gardiens de la révolution
aujourd'hui le chef du mouvement a
promis une riposte à tout acte des états
unis par ailleurs terran dit vouloir
enrichir de l'uranium jusqu'à 20 % un
niveau bien au dessus du seuil autorisé
par l'accord de vienne 2015
elles iront ensemble s'en désengager
petit à petit une façon de mettre la
pression sur la communauté
internationale comme nous l'expliquent
grâce d'allah téhéran s'affranchit des
exigences fixées par l'accord de vienne
une information rendue publique vendredi
par l' agence internationale de
l'énergie atomique est athée par une
lettre du 31 décembre qui ne précise
toutefois pas la date du début de ce
projet d'enrichissement
l'iran a informé l'agencé que pour se
conformer à un acte juridique récemment
adopté par le parlement du pays
l'organisation de l'énergie atomique de
l'iran à l'intention de produire de
l'uranium faiblement enrichi jusqu'à 20%
à l' usine d'enrichissement du
combustible de fordo une information qui
a fuité tardivement en raison des fêtes
de fin d'année le directeur général a
informé le conseil supérieur et le
commandement spatial des nations unies
de l'intention de téhéran de démarrer
une opération d'enrichissement d'uranium
à 20%
habituellement ces rapports
confidentiels sont divulguées aux médias
en dix minutes
aujourd'hui c'est passé environ deux
heures 20 % 1 seuils nettement supérieur
aux 3,67 % fixé par l'accord de vienne
de 2015 imposé sur une durée de 15 ans
mais depuis le retrait américain en mai
2018 et les sanctions américaines
l'accord devient bancal l'iran décide
alors d'imposer son rythme aux futures
négociations tant que perdure les
sanctions notamment américaines et
européennes dans les secteurs de la
finance de l'énergie et du transport
iranien
mais changement de cap depuis fin
novembre après l'assassinât du physicien
nucléaire iranien mohsen fakhrizadeh
l'ale la plus dure de téhéran a promis
une riposte une loi controversée a
immédiatement été adoptée elle préconise
la production et le stockage d'au moins
120 kg par an d'uranium enrichi à 20% et
de stopper les inspections de l'agencé
internationale de l'énergie atomique
les démocraties ne peuvent pas demander
à l'iran de violer la législation
parlementaire est signataire de l'accord
notamment la chine l'allemagne la france
ou le royaume-uni joue la montre tablant
sur l'arrivée du démocrate joe biden à
la maison blanche
ce dernier avait affirmé que les états
unis reviendraient au table des
négociations si les rangs respecte les
restrictions nucléaire mais pour téhéran
l'enrichissement d'uranium reste un
moyen de pression nécessaire face aux
sanctions qui se multiplient à son égard
pour l'heure le dossier du nucléaire
iranien risque de se retrouver devant le
conseil de sécurité de l'onu et de faire
voler en éclats l'accord de vienne de
2015 déjà bien fragile
on va écouter thierry coville chercheur
à l'iris spécialiste de l'iran selon lui
téhéran cherche à faire revenir les
états unis à la table des négociations
je pense que c'est un moyen de pression
l'iran voire message gouvernement
américain si vous ne revenez pas dans
l'accord
si vous ne supprimez pas immédiatement
les sanctions auraient imposé par trump
voilà ce qui pourrait selon ses rois ni
grande lan wan y étaient contre cette
loi en disant que ça va compliquer les
négociations je lui ai fait une
déclaration disant calmez vous laissez
nous négocier on sait faire dans le
parlement iranien je pense qu'il ya une
bougie qu'électoral on sait qu'il ya des
élections présidentielles en iran en
juin 2021 rallye bof qu'est le président
du parlement a des visées
présidentielles
donc je pense qu'il ya peut-être un
calcul chez un certain nombre de
radicaux
l'idée c'est que on bloque les
négociations avec les américains et
c'est nous si jamais présente rallye
boffo quelqu'un radical été élu aux
élections présidentielles en juin 2011
terre c'est nous qui négocieront avec
les amis au niger comme annoncé par à la
commission électorale mohamed bazoum a
est arrivé en tête des suffrages avec un
peu plus de 39% des voix et le candidat
du parti au pouvoir affrontera
l'ancien président mahamane ousmane qui
a récolté près de 17% des voix et
mohamed bazoum l'ancien ministre de
l'intérieur qui espérait une victoire
dès le premier tour se voit donc obligé
de trouver de nouveaux soutiens pour le
second tour qui se tiendra le 20 février
prochain
à noter que le taux de participation de
ce scrutin du premier tour était proche
de 70% et c'est la fin de ce journal
merci à vous de l'avoir suivi on va se
retrouver en direct pas bien sûr en 30
minutes
restez avec nous sur rt france
[Musique]
des organes d'un flux ans de propagande
et de propagande mensongère
richard good est montreuil pour le
château
[Musique]
alors non mais vous êtes fous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je n'ai pas pu faire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et y'a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre la table
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi qui dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du pays il
est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
des sous les libéraux l'uniforme c'est
quand même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inouï tg les gens ne
s'étaient des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstitue